oui américains et soviétiques devons
donc prendre à nouveau rendez vous pour
tenter de dégager un accord définitif
c'est sans doute l'une des conditions de
la sécurité du monde car sinon sinon
tout peut être imaginé tout y compris le
pire comme ce scénario de politique
fiction conçu par un stratège
britannique un reportage de michel v
la troisième guerre mondiale commence au
début de l'été 1985 yougoslavie le pays
s'est rapproché du camp occidental après
la mort de tito les soviétiques
réagissent rapidement le 27 juillet 1985
une division de parachutistes soviétique
s'empare de belgrade le président des
états unis envoient ces marines alou
vienne 24 heures après les marines
américains combattent les troupes
parachutistes russes
cet incident donne au commandement russe
le prétexte longtemps attendu ses
troupes envahissent la manne fédérale et
la scandinavie leur objectif le rhin les
premiers chars soviétiques t-72 et t-90
franchissent la frontière de la
république fédérale allemande en
formation serrée le matin du 4 août 1985
l'offensive alliée du 15 août met en
échec les troupes du pacte de varsovie
les soulèvements populaires éclatent
partout en urss certaine division russe
commence à se mutiner les soviétiques
doivent évacuer l'allemagne à moscou les
faucons décide d'utiliser le feu
nucléaire le matin du 20 août un missile
est 16-17 explose au centre le dernier
emboîtant trois cent mille personnes
meurent en quelques minutes quelques
heures plus tard deux missiles
américains anéantissent minsk en urss la
peur de la guerre nucléaire totale
déclenché une révolte des nationalités
en urss qui porte un coup fatal au
système soviétique la troisième guerre
mondiale a duré moins de trois semaines
ce scénario n'est pas dû à un auteur de
science-fiction mais à l'un des
meilleurs experts militaires occidentaux
le général à kate
oh
le général hackett ancien commandant de
l'armée britannique du rhin nous dit
pourquoi il a écrit le livre publié à
londres sous le titre la troisième
guerre mondiale août 85
ce n'est pas une prévision pas du tout
je suis pas prophète
mais je suis sûr que si dans nos pays de
l'ouest de l'alliance atlantique
nous ne faisons beaucoup mieux nous ne
faisons à présent pendant de défense que
dans un tel cas
notre état serait très très difficile
tout le monde n'est pas du même avis les
responsables politiques de l'otan''
pense que le général ac est sûre estime
le potentiel de l'armée rouge en tout
cas on ne pourra pas accuser le général
keith de manquer d'humour interrogé sur
le point de savoir pourquoi il avait
choisi en ligne gamme comme objectif de
la bombe atomique russe il a répondu je
n'ai jamais aimé birmingham
[Musique]